Hi, Jake, good morning.
Good morning.
How are you?
I'm good.
back to work this week from head surgery on Monday.
Yeah. Yeah, I've talked to Derek earlier and he just got back from a leave. So hope it's, hope you feel better soon.
Yeah, I mean, I had surgery on Monday, so...
We're getting there.
Yeah.
So, are we waiting for someone?
And by the way, Jacob, I do apologize because Andrea will not be joining because she's sick. She's sick since yesterday. I think she still has some fever right now. So you just mentioned that there's a few questions that she wanted to ask, so I'll just going to deliver that later.
Okay.
Shall we start?
Yep.
Okay, so I'm going to share my screen.
Alright, so do you see my screen now?
Yes.
Okay, so welcome to the monthly business review for May 2026. So before we start, Jacob, anything in particular that we need to know, like updates or changes in terms of the procedures that you want or you have there in place at the moment?
First implement for Erik.
Right now, no. We are working on a lot of things.
in terms of automations and things like that. So there will be stuff changing, but we don't have anything right now.
Okay. All right. Thank you for that. So, yeah, highlights attendance for Derek. Derek has been in a perfect attendance trick for the month of April and May. Sorry for that. And with no lates and absences. And then he mentioned yesterday
He expressed his appreciation to you for the support that he continues to receive. And he said, you're very approachable in terms of personal or work related. So he enjoys the support that you're giving him. So
Yeah.
He just want to thank you for those kind of things, especially the support system that he's having from you. So.
Good.
Yeah.
Okay, so performance analysis, basically this is the KPIs that we have. Utilization target is 80%, ticket results per day is 8 to 10, CSAT 95, rewards and recognition 30%, SLA 95%, first touch resolution 90%, and same day resolution rate is 80%.
Okay.
So at the moment, I'm not sure if this is how they deliver this to you, but I've added as well the non-billable utilization so that you're going to see. So basically for the week one to week three, it's running 20, 23% to 22%.
every week and the non-billables are quite low. And on the 4th week, the reason why it's kind of high is because the ticket report, he admitted that he just came back as well from Lee, so he didn't get a chance to update the production tracker.
That I have, but...
Moving forward, I mentioned to him that if it's possible that he could just provide the scores or the production reports on a daily basis just to be accurate in terms of the utilization. So insights, Derek showed strong recovery after initial dip, sustaining above target performance in subsequent weeks.
The consistent ability to reach or exceeds targets, especially under higher volumes, suggests improving efficiency and stable delivery capability. So any questions so far, Jacob, in regards to the utilization report?
No.
Uh, I've been sending, I've been sending a report to...
Okay.
Andrea.
To address.
Should I start including you with that?
Okay.
Yeah, if it's possible, starting starting next month or maybe first week of June, which is okay, yeah, weekly will do. That will be a big help.
Kip.
So, yeah, so I send it weekly.
So, yeah, so you'll get...
Two documents from me next Wednesday for this week to report.
Mhm.
Okay. All right. Thank you so much for that. And then I'll just going to input that manually on our system so that I can keep track on the performance and the workload that he has. So yeah, thank you. Next one is ticket closure trend and analysis. So
Kip.
basically occurred week 2 and week 4, both achieving 100% resolution rate, observed in one week at 77%, falling slightly below 80% target. This may indicate initial backlog, adjustment period, or process efficiencies early in the cycle. So
I'm not sure if there's some changes in regards to the ticket allocation that Derek has on week two or week one of May. But yeah, he's working. Or I just want to check, Jacob, in regards to week two.
one in week 3 on the tickets that he worked on. Is this normal, the ticket number that he has, the quantity like 26 to 29 tickets per week?
Mhm.
Um...
Yeah, I mean...
Like looking at where he's at and...
Some of the others on my team, I mean, there's obviously going to be our much lower level help, like desktop tech levels that are doing a lot of the really quick, easy ones, like password resets and things like that, who may be doing, you know, more than that. But for Derek, that's a really good number.
Mhm.
Okay, but does Derek has like complex tickets? Like do you guys also support Mac OS for some clients? So does he support or work on those kind of tickets or does he need like a...
Yep.
a training for those kind of things.
No, he should be working those if he's been assigned.
OK, alright, I'll that.
There's.
Yeah, I know we don't have a ton of Mac environments, but we do have a few clients. So he would be expected to be able to do.
Mhm.
at least basic level troubleshooting. And then we have...
Mm.
Blake.
Actually, on my team specifically, we have one of our guys who's like one of our more Mac.
heavy technicians.
Mhm.
that most people go to if they have questions or need help with something.
Okay, so basically, like, for example, Derek has like the overview, just for the overview of Mac OS, like supporting OS update or application install, something like that. Is that one of the samples or some of the samples that Derek is working on for?
E.
Mac OS.
Yeah, it would be troubleshooting.
Microsoft 365 on a Mac.
Mhm.
And yeah, basic level OS operating stuff and then.
I don't think we have, I don't think any of our Mac clients are using a VPN, so that's good.
Okay, alright.
So yeah, that's pretty much it.
Okay, so yeah, we're going to proceed on the customer satisfaction. So I've just checked this earlier, and he has at least nine CSAT responses for the month of May. Score of 10 is 6 responses, and then one, 9, and two score of eight.
So he received a perfect score of 9, which is excellent. We only have a small portion of 8 and 9, which give us a clear focus area to improve and push more on the results into perfect scores. So is this a normal number in regards to the CSAT scores that you guys have, or it's...
It's kinda low at the moment.
In terms of the number of CSATs returned?
Mhm.
That's, yeah, that's pretty average.
It's pretty fair, like 9 to 10 per month.
I'd have to look. I haven't checked.
But per technician, yeah, 9 to 10 per month is pretty good.
Mhm, Okay.
And then yeah, anything 8 or above, we're happy with.
Mhm.
And then anything below that is where we would have potential room for coaching and things like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, we might need to discuss that if it's lower than eight. Okay. All right. Thank you. I'm going to take note of that. Oh, it's hi, Manu. So, Jacob, this is Manu. So he's going to be jumping in to the service call since Andrew's been around.
Okay.
Hi, Jacob.
And Manu.
Long time, no see.
No, no problem.
And so.
Love you, you take care.
Okay, so let's continue. Way forward. So I mentioned, or Derek mentioned that he's practicing coordinating the dispatch team for ticket allocations. Like if he wants more tickets, he's going to coordinate that to your dispatch personnel.
So is that okay? That's the question, to bypass someone or just approach directly the dispatcher so that they can assign tickets to him?
Yes.
Yep, I would suggest he open up a chat with both of our dispatch individuals, Justin and Nick, and just if he's if he's showing that he's got like 2 tickets left and needs more work.
Mhm.
That's like the best time to reach out, because that way he has something he can do while they're working on getting him work, whether it's from...
Mmh.
our regular ticket board or if it's like a...
Service alert or something like that.
Okay, but do you guys have like some small projects that we can, you know, assign to Derek?
Or does, is he doing that already?
So projects, we have a whole project team.
It handles all of that. And if there's ever any need from their side to request resources from my side, we assign as we need, but there's not really much we can do in that realm. I could sit with Jerek and give him some tips on what he can do to look for tickets.
Mhm.
Because there are some pretty easy, quick.
keyword searches and things like that we can do.
Quick fix, yeah.
Mm.
Okay, so what I'll be doing from my end is I'm going to double check the top code drivers that he has on that. If there's some room for improvement in terms of the tickets that he's handling, maybe if he gets used to it or there's additional knowledge that he can apply to those tickets.
maybe the resolution time is much faster so that he can get more tickets on the bucket and yeah, most likely coordinating it to the dispatch team.
Yep.
Okay. All right. Next one is ITBD holiday on June 12th. It's Independence Day here in the Philippines. So question is, do you need Derek to report to work on that day? It's A Friday.
Right, let me take a look real quick to see.
Uh, but next week.
No, he should be fine to have that day off.
Okay, all right, I'm gonna take note of that. Thank you. So, yeah, next question is Build IT Live 2026 in New Jersey. Is someone coming? Because I'm gonna understand if you will not be joining because of the, you know, operation that you have and you need to.
Yeah.
Recover.
Yeah, no, I don't think at this time it's going to work out for us to be able to do that.
Okay, all right, I understand. Thank you. So, yeah, Team GPS, I know, right, this was explained to you before, but if you're interested, just let us know and we're going to help you to, you know, try to, you can try this Team GPS that we have. It's pretty basic.
and user-friendly. And yeah, you can just either send me an email or Andrea for this.
Okay.
All right, so yeah. Anything to add, Jacob, in regards to Jerick's performance, or you need to, or is there something that we need to improve in regards to how Jerick performs on a daily basis?
No, I think he's been doing really well.
Okay, alright. Any any questions so far?
Um...
Nope.
or other things that we need to talk about.
I don't have anything though.
Okay, Manu, how about you?
No, I have no questions. Jacob, good to hear from you after a long time.
Yeah, you too.
Yeah.
Hope everything goes well, Jacob, for your operation on Monday. My prayers will be with you.
Thank you.
All right, you take care. Thank you so much, guys, for joining this service call. Have a great day. Bye-bye.
Yep.
Thank you, Mark. Thank you, Jacob. Bye.
Bye.